huo's pass across Anderson shoots in the traffic
rebound comes free hubo scores hubo Banks it in
off the skate of Levi and the Flames take a one
nothing lead aloso back up top darene to the far
side shot [Applause] scor Eric Johnson back to
Rasmus Anderson dropped it off hanin shot just
wide big bounce in front Sharon Gage played it
in front another chance der scores Walker der
we play with 127 remaining Thompson fire Circle
scor there it is for Tage Thompson he opens his
story count of the Season Bon leading the shift
knocked down an aggressive play by Gilbert he'll
take off try and take off with it gets away four
plays over the line Gilbert hits the trailer
there's Tado the pass they score comes back to
the point Yoki Haru lays it to the wall gets it
back again up top of the Zone down the right
side cousins in the middle of the ice scores
duay in a battle knocked down along the board
flams get it again he SC rra hble to snap at
home and Adam [Applause] roska Lawrence joins
the battle Puck comes up the boards the stenland
he moves he fires he scores now the Matthews line
pined in its own Zone final seconds barov looking
to give someone a chance emman Larson shoots
he scores and the put scen wide neander back
to tomorrow's a hard josi save rebound score five
to go Marner kned away and the Florida Panthers
walking shots grind it out and the empty from
Reinhardt working hard Smith to keep the puck in
Sherwood tries to turn the corner Twisted back
looking for MC the follow Barry a drive and a
rebound score for part of the season in Washington
picked up up out of the Boxx comes Smith and he's
got it on a breakaway Ryan orelli behind him Smith
scores two goals in the first period Nashville
is 0 for one tonight on the power play high slot
O'Reilly they move it quickly to forb right there
O'Reilly star outstanding passing starting with
Barry and riy forsburg drives through one wave of
blue jersey forsberg scores Philip forsberg the
Daron look scored the net gets it back toana Jad
Fox into the Chris [Applause] score there's the
loose Puck again giv up to Paul side of oh what
a save another shot and Deco got that the rebound
than go and the captain Quinn Hughes delays before
sending the puck forward Miller kns it into the
champion stolen behind the goal T in front B
scores after a most successful opening shift of
the period for that Trio Patterson Off the Bench
keeps the puck in finds Myers with the room Tyler
Myers shoots he scores toan to perix up to Center
for Conor Sherry back the other way from Mikey Aon
he's in scor couple of big guys there there's a
long range shot knocked down by dco here's KRA
again KRA dances shoot St as Demco came cross
and shut the angle down Paul wins the puck battle
steps out hangs on C SC hooks it back to Hughes
Quinn Hughes Philip Heron gets a return pass long
shot block it away Miller storms on the rebound
swatted it right out of midair and kulak will
skate it out of the zone and Chip it up towards
Fogle nice play by Sano to get it right to Faby
and back on the Flyers watch out for bar to Brak
bar McDavid is going to flex that left knee and
make a change Here Comes tippet now tipp's got
ainson in front goes to him SC see if woodc starts
to throw some of these lines in a in a blender a
bit and right now he is himman with McDavid and
drle score taking away those shooting lanes and
stealing the puck and here they come shorthanded
shot SC and what does he want to do too how
long is the rebuild going to take ainson in L
[Applause] score Pat maroon and D hay and those
that have been following Minnesota first week and
a half of the Season say this has been night after
night their best line here's grundstrom a chance
and he scores and here's your one three through
the neutral zone let's see if the wild can work
their way through the maze get the puck up on
the glass and they score Hartman has it back off
the wall for zuk Carell into the middle drive by
Bine and they score tipped by caprisa kopitar's
line back out and off the draw tipped to Kee a
shot through traffic block loose score picked up
by fiala who clears it up the right wing boards a
foot race after it dubba to the net dubba scores
PL dubba well a pretty eventful first period
coming to a close turnover dub shoots and scores
kind of a strange puck drop there on that face off
yeah normally they blow that type of play Down cab
leaving it in front and a chance and a goal Trevor
Moore loose Puck Johansson has e and he
scores for zuk Carell feeds it behind the
net it's in front on a deflection But Eric
Z couldn't H it up empty net shot and a goal
being hounded got it in deep capris off shoots
save is made CA off a great look maybe his
best of the night and now an empty net shot
score back of the line balamaki here they
come again melli across scores nowhere to
go schaltz on the counter here come the
coyotes to the front and go oh Clayton
Keller and he's done it again in St Louis wow
two nothing coyotes Now Kevin Hayes back in
shop it off the glass that rings around to
scandella now right in front BR shoots he
scores dersy trying to advance it coyotes will
take it away here they come carcone carcone
to the FR scores off in front ky's trying to
come away with a loose Puck they do right to
the front schal P Henry scores Nick schalton
what a setup sha dery back out high again on
the coyotes for melli and they get it set up
Mattias machell goes across shot and a goal
we'll see if Craig Ruby has any other changes
toer brought in front they score Sammy BL on a
great feed and bl makes it [Music] 52 Jersey's
got it he walks right down the middle he scores
Corner shot by dery as eel tried to steal that
one now n rider at Center Martinez broke his
stick here's Josh morresy over the line head up
shoots a rebound scar Stone takes it in Around
the Net Michel out top Theodore thought about
letting that fly moves it instead the Stevenson
now maruso scores and the puck back to Dylan
Dello stone with a steal has how and in front he
scores got runs it in deep Carlson rolls feeds
it Martinez with a Chance scores down two now
to the Stanley Cup chance not a great drop pass
and eers will take it into the Zone Nikolai eers
for nestic call for Benny stor backed over to the
Conor heers is at the left Point morisy gives it
to Nikolai eers shle set up a follow scor Appleton
went down as he tried to clear Stone looking Mel
with a chance and his scores Theodore back on it
lead pass to WAN with an open net in front of him
Juan looking scores back to mov tries to float it
towards the net pelski blocked it but he got it
back zbra SZ a one time AG go that rebound score
for Troy Terry up to the time when they really
need to win a draw pelski feeding in front hits
he scores hinan good there J it's Robertson for
hinan again R shot tip score pelski [Applause]
couldn't further it along and now possible two
onone Terry gets on his horse across the line
with Carlson Carlson score it's game three of
the season here's samam steel feeding hkin and
has a lane left side drops it in front score
this way it's Andre burkovski he'll rethink
it shootting it stepped in Yan gor the pepper
pot on the spot one of those players that you
mentioned trip does heavy lifting now slayen
with a shot this score Carolina with the answer
right away getting to those pucks just a little
bit quicker see how needs to do in the defensive
Zone MOS Shu can see no power play Schwarz scor
25 seconds left in the kill done a shot kicked
out they score short hand and goal hits first as
a kraken from burkovski Jaden Schwarz has a power
play goal tonight for Seattle done with a shot he
St P coov stopped all six shots that he faced
Noth Carolina sending it across JIS he scores
oh what a setup and there's the quick goal Jarvis
looking for the puck he spots Burns at the point
said he'll turn it back down low n behind the net
he'll get it to cookie near me they score turns
off the glass in play poked Along by Bor strand
will get away from n to the slot they score the
balance is back scoring balance as huged by NIS
they play on and a penalty will be called they
score D'Angelo with a keep in across for NES NIS
looks for a lane up top D'Angelo NIS onetime right
out in front rebound they score Seth Jarvis six
skaters empty net situation Bullseye Oliver borr
74 Ken to take him and his shot away denado turns
it over Far Side from Colorado looking to break
here's the opportunity short-handed score off
the face off here's McKinnon he goes cross set
in front unbelievable save by morassi loose Puck
still Lo and now it's in Tyler Johnson turns it
right over well it's been a dominant effort by
Colorado unbelievable wide open net for Devon
K and the abent jump on the rebound you're
right Ray McKinnon sniffing for one here's
a chance shot scor forber stabs it ahead beer
rotating Maran closes scores visit your local
New England Audi dealer today Frederick jams away
and the Bruins have their sticks in the air Carlo
breaks it up poock with Maran poock and the puck
is in the goal geeky off the faceof for marshad
who's tied up by Burrows now a lead pass for
Anthony duclair duclair to the net and he's gone